this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream use the link in the description
to watch thousands of documentaries and
for the same price exclusive and add
free videos from your favorite creators
on nebula of the countless companies
industries and facets of life affected
by the corona virus pandemic one stands
out in particular college admissions
while airlines can be bailed out
workplaces can adapt and the unemployed
can expect some degree of emergency
support for high school juniors and
seniors 2020 represents not just one
year of lost income or hardship but
potentially a lifetime this and next
year's graduating class have a lot to
gain or lose from changes in college
admissions and were therefore watching
closely to see how they would respond
first the College Board announced AP
tests would go online after preparing
all year for the very specific
approximately three hour format
consisting of both multiple choice and
free responses the test would be
shortened to 45 minutes include only the
written section and also be sent to
teachers while some praised the College
Board for adapting to the circumstances
in just eight weeks others raised
concerns of fairness this year to
prevent cheating every student took
their exams at the same time meaning for
example a student in California would
begin their computer science test at the
convenient time of 11:00 a.m. while
someone in Tokyo would have to start at
3:00 a.m. not all students of course
have the same access to technology or a
calm quiet testing environment some
simply got unlucky
their Wi-Fi stopped working or their
phones froze and had to retake it the
SAT was in even worse shape in March as
new coronavirus cases exploded in the
u.s. many testing centers were forced to
close sometimes on short or no notice
the May and then June SATs were canceled
and preparations are now being made for
fall after first announcing it would
also go online the College Board has
now reverse that decision saying it
plans on holding one test a month from
August through the end of the year all
in person knowing these circumstances a
number of schools begin dropping their
SAT and a CT requirements Dartmouth
Harvard Princeton Yale Stanford Cornell
all UC schools and hundreds of others
have announced they're becoming test
optional for at least the next year but
rather than delaying the course of
history
the coronavirus seems to be propelling
it forward five 10 or even 15 years what
was before unthinkable not going to the
movies working from home and learning
from your laptop is now being forced
upon us setting a precedent that may
extend far beyond the virus if employees
can work just as effectively from home
without the cost of running an office
why not keep doing so and if this batch
of students can skip the SAT why can't
all the first thing to note is that test
optional may not mean what you think it
does many schools require scores from
all applicants but on the other end of
the spectrum only a very small number
are test blind meaning even if students
submit them they'll only be used for
things like financial aid not admissions
most are somewhere in between
some schools forgo test scores for
students who meet a certain threshold
GPA or class rank others vary based on
major and finally about 700 allow
students to decide themselves test
optional doesn't necessarily mean scores
aren't important make admissions easier
or that you shouldn't submit them it
does mean that if you don't submit them
you'll need other strong qualifications
to stay competitive and here lies the
puzzle if a school believes standardized
test to be a strong predictor of college
success one would expect them to be
mandatory on the other hand if they
don't you'd expect schools to not even
consider them why would so many schools
allow students to decide how much
information to give them information
which could affect their graduation rate
academic performance and eventually
endowment
a few clues may help answer this
question research shows a few things
usually happen when schools go test
optional first more students apply
naturally when universities make it
easier to do so whether by using the
common application or removing
requirements like test scores more will
of course schools aren't accepting more
applicants which means their acceptance
rates go down and they appear more
selective second their average test
scores are higher each student knows all
of his or her scores and individually
decides whether to submit them based on
whether or not they'll increase their
odds of getting admitted students with
higher scores will choose to submit them
while those with lower ones will more
likely not inflating their accepted
schools average statistics in theory
this shouldn't matter
the College Board explicitly states that
SAT scores should not be used to compare
schools and yet they are by going test
optional schools may improve on college
rankings even if their true average
scores actually decreased 7.75% of the
US News College ranking formula for
example is based on SAT and a CT scores
although this number is discounted by
15% if fewer than three-quarters of new
students in a particular year don't
submit scores it still leaves plenty of
room for schools to game the system
either by ensuring seventy five point
one percent of students submit or by
making up for the discount with
extremely high average scores bond
rating agencies also use average scores
to assess a school student demand and
from it determine creditworthiness
finally a third effect of going test
optional is disputed it may increase
diversity the question is do
standardized tests help alleviate or
amplify inequality some studies suggest
the former while others come to the
latter conclusion in general admissions
officers agree that the number one best
predictors of college success are
similar high school classes like a PE IB
and honors it's no surprise that arduous
semester or year long
courses would better prepare students
for arduous semester or year-long
courses then say a three-hour exam by
itself the difficulty is that every
teacher and every high school and every
city county and state teaches and grades
differently it's also been observed that
grades are inflating over time there are
far fewer C's and DS and far more A's
and B's today than there were ten years
ago
thus admissions offices can and should
treat high school GPA as the most
important metric the College Board
argues but combined with national
standardized SAT scores to compare and
confirm these numbers between schools
how much the SAT adds in predictive
power researchers disagree but
admissions officers tend to agree that
high grades and low test scores are
better than the reverse and it's these
students who stand to benefit from test
optional policies they're
disproportionately first-generation to
college women low-income and speak a
second language at home while the SAT
may confirm high GPAs for most students
it may make someone in this group look
worse for no good reason for example
they may not have access to test prep or
have the free time to take the exam
several times it's widely known that
household income is strongly correlated
with test performance and for obvious
reasons test fees while insignificant
for high-income households can be
prohibitive for the poor many low income
students are given two free SAT exams
but wealthy students are still more
likely to have taken the SAT multiple
times schools in wealthier areas also
provide greater assistance with the SAT
and college admissions
not to mention private help many studies
suggest test prep leads to an overall
twenty to thirty point increase on the
SAT sometimes only by teaching
test-taking strategies rather than
actual material tests coaches another
branch of the SAT economy sometimes
helped their clients apply for learning
disabilities in order to obtain more
time on the exam on the other hand test
optional policies place greater emphasis
on things like high school curriculum
and extracurricular activities both of
which are less accessible in some areas
and for some socio-economic groups
avoiding the SAT in other words may
simply introduce a new form of
inequality but while not requiring the
SAT and a CT may or may not help
increase diversity it definitely helps
strengthen other metrics like acceptance
rate which makes schools look more
selective it's impossible to know which
of these reasons truly motivate schools
to try test optional policies but it
does strongly suggest why they stay that
way schools now say they're adjusting
this and next year's requirements to
help ease the hardships faced by
students which should come as no
surprise at a time when they expect
fewer applicants and greater financial
difficulties this year the University of
California schools president made
headlines for announcing that all UC
schools will be test optional for the
next two years then test blind for two
more after that
and then phase out the SAT and a CT
completely critics have praised the
decision for making higher education
more fair and diverse except the UC
system isn't abandoning standardized
testing but to creating its own test to
use instead in many ways it's
reminiscent of 2001 when the then UC
president delivered a speech
recommending it schools abandoned the
SAT which prompted the College Board to
redesign the test whether intentional or
not these are negotiations not so subtle
reminders to the College Board that it's
true customers aren't students but
schools and that if it can't create the
test schools want they can make it
themselves if you're a student you've
probably realized that learning from
home is tough it requires more
self-discipline motivation and study
skills well lucky for you it just so
happens I in a bunch of other youtubers
have created Nebula a new streaming
service for the best educational videos
so you can learn new study habits expand
your knowledge and take a break with
exclusive high-quality originals ad-free
and on all your devices we've partnered
with curiosity stream so that when you
sign
for their collection of thousands of
high-quality history science and nature
documentaries you also get access to
nebula at no extra cost right now it's
on sale for just $15 a year or just
under a dollar 25 a month this is a
fantastic deal and all you have to do is
use my link in the description after
which you'll get an email with access to
nebula